let's go next to our caller from the
three-two-three area code who's calling
today from 3 to 3 hey Mark what's going
on well yeah I was just were you one of
the people that push the narrative that
the Russians had impacted our elections
I mean I saw some interesting reports
suggesting that it's possible because of
how close it was in certain states that
their social media interference could at
least hypothetically mathematically have
been the difference maker but it's not
you know in some when you have a
thousand factors that impact an outcome
it's hard to say this one thing was
definitely the difference maker well how
did they want apply the number of people
they claimed work that good right I mean
it's like okay so you look at Wisconsin
Hillary Clinton didn't go to Wisconsin
towards the end how many votes went to
Trump over Hillary because of that then
you have to contrast that with how many
people were targeted in with Wisconsin
by foreign dollars in social media
campaigns and then what percentage of
them voted differently or didn't vote is
over I mean you're getting it to exactly
the point which is there are a thousand
different things James Comey coming out
and talking about the Hillary Clinton
investigation what impact did that have
on voting in Wisconsin so it's very
difficult to say with any certainty this
one thing is what decided but we can
still talk about the number of factors
that played a role if that makes sense
yes but did this Russian campaign was it
meant to influence Hillary voters to
vote for Trump I I don't know
specifically what campaigns they ran in
any particular state I'm they are more
sophisticated than just saying let's get
Hillary voters to vote for Trump they
you know one of the strategies that they
used was to foment racial anxiety around
police shootings in places like Ferguson
and Baltimore it's it's more nuanced
than let's find Hillary vote
and feed them disinformation to get them
to vote Trump it's not that I think that
might be too simplistic of an
understanding of what these kam how
these campaigns work yeah because my
belief is like I'm up with firm belief
that most people on the Left are more
intelligent than the people on the right
hmm why do you believe that um
well because there's a lot of uneducated
low-income people who vote Republican
right I mean there's also people who are
low-income to work for Democrats too I
mean idea
I'm not saying I agree or disagree with
you I'm saying how do you justify that's
a pretty bold assertion to say generally
the left is smarter than the right no
just basically on certain statistics
that I've seen that most of the most
college-educated people are are liberal
on the left so that it's a little bit
different so the more education you have
the more likely you are to be more left
than right that is true yes okay so
based on that right I'm a firm believer
that yeah the people on the Left are
intelligent there there are a lot of
college educated intelligent people and
I'm just wondering how intelligent
college-educated people would have been
fooled into believing obvious lies
because I'm of the firm belief that this
whole idea of Russian influence it never
happened because I wasn't influenced by
by Russian I you know I I didn't vote
for Hillary not because of anything okay
yeah but now you're hello oh you do not
know you're cutting in and out listen
what you you were one out of a hundred
and twenty million voters so the fact
that you were weren't influenced by any
particular thing doesn't doesn't really
tell us that much one way or the other
but mark you're thinking about these
things the right way I'm gonna let you
go cuz you're breaking breaking up and I
do it's been months since we heard from
him months and months and months let's
go to oh no we just lost him we just had
someone I wanted to go to that we had
not heard from for months who I wanted
to talk to okay well on that note I am
over time already so that does it for
today sorry to everybody that I was not
able to get to on the phones today
we'll take calls again I will be
live-streaming in the next week and that
is another opportunity to call in as the
phones often do open we'll take a quick
break and be back with more right after
this